bonjour bonjour bienvenue dans diagonale
tv spéciale grand champion de l'histoire
du jeu d'échecs avec notre expert
historique gerome on fera celle jérôme
on rappelait d'ailleurs que tu dis
experts parce que tu as fait beaucoup de
d'articles de fond sur l'histoire du jeu
dans le magazine de la fédération
française d'échecs notamment échec et
mat
oui on s'est amusé à retracer l'histoire
des grands champions depuis philidor
jusqu'à ira jusqu'à un homme d'image il
voilà donc un peu dans la filiation de
de notre expert précédent j'ai envie de
dire nicolas giffard wii qui quittent
toujours là d'ailleurs qui est toujours
actif et cafés sont magnifiques aussi
l'histoire fabuleuse des champions
d'échecs et tu prends la suite alors
donc c'est lui le vrai expert moi je
suis un admirateur de décalage il part
comme tout le monde j'ai lycée j'ai lu
ses livres ses skis ski sont des bibles
pour tous les joueurs d'échecs
maintenant c'est vrai que j'aime bien
explorer l'histoire est enseignant en
histoire géographie dans le passé et
donc c'est resté un grand intérêt pour
moi voilà donc aujourd'hui ben point
historique fondamentale
j'ai envie de dire du jeu d'échecs
puisqu'on va retracer la carrière d'un 2
sans doute le plus grand le plus grand
de tous les champions du monde d'échecs
bobby fischer le très grand le kid de
brooklyn
et oui puisqu'il est né à new york en
effectivement quand on commence à parler
de fisher on un seul souci c'est savoir
à quel moment on doit arrêter parce qu
on aurait énormément de choses à dire
c'est un petit peu comme quand on
littérature s'attaque à rimbaud il ya
tellement de biographies ya tellement de
choses qui ont été dites écrites ya
tellement de légende autour de bobby
fischer qu'on ne sait plus exactement où
commence la légende et où se termine la
réalité oui donc in et donc à brooklyn
en 1143 est alors des dès 14 ans il
obtient des résultats extraordinaires
il est champion des états unis à 14 ans
ça c'est énorme c'est absolument
incroyable
il est grand maître international je
crois à 15 ans de quasiment dans la
foulée le plus jeune à l'époque je lui
fis détiennent un record d'ailleurs je
crois que c'est judit polgar qui a battu
ce record est très longtemps après c'est
exactement ça je ne le garde pas ce
record 1991 et puis ensuite on a eu
d'autres grands maîtres qui ont été très
très très précoce des années 90 2000
mais à l'époque de bobby fischer s'est
quand même c'est quand même lui qui est
véritablement le prodige
alors comment ils démarrent pas comment
ils démarrent c'est un garçon qui n'aime
pas spécialement l'école les seuls
témoignages qu'on est de lui de son
enfance et de ceux d'un enfant qui était
au fond de la classe et qui lisait soit
des bd soit des livres d'échecs russe
en gros c'était à peu près ces deux
centres d'intérêts comme moi ouais en
gros un petit peu comme toi
cet arrêté un soupçon de plus de talent
mais bon ça fait cher pour bénéficiaires
teaser zehti bref c'est pas c'est pas le
premier de la classe
il mène sa vie à lui il est dans son
monde
il est déjà dans son monde qui est celui
des grands maîtres soviétique dont il
lit les livres il est recueilli deux
parties et puis et puis s'en inspire
bien sûr pour développer son jeu il joue
beaucoup dans les clubs de new york
il faut souligner quand même c'est un
arrière-plan qui est intéressant qu'il
n'a pas de son père à la maison il est
seul et seul avec sa mère qui s'appelle
regina oui la reine en latin d'accord on
peut en italien donc on peut
on peut se livrer à toutes sortes de
spéculations psychologique
à partir de là il obtient très vite des
résultats absolument époustouflant
surtout dans un environnement américain
où il ya de très bons joueurs mais il
n'y a pas une école américaine comme il
peut y avoir une école soviétique bobby
fischer iléo c'est aussi un météore un
petit peu comme mort filles et au 19e
siècle
à noter d'ailleurs qu'il apprend
relativement tard parce que c'est
septembre quand il débute le jeu qui est
vraiment qu'il apprend que c'est à dire
que ça fait partie des championnes qui
apprennent presque le plus tard
finalement donc puisque l'écart pauvreté
14 des 5-6 ans il commençait déjà à
savoir à peu près jouer oui karpov
commencent eux-mêmes d'euros la légende
veut 4 5 ans kasparov s'est à peu près
dans les mêmes eaux
effectivement on va dire que c'est
tardif à 7 ans mais c'est pas non plus
c'est pas non plus la première chose
qu'il a peint en tout cas ensuite ici
ici plonge et il s'y projette absolument
entièrement il le dit lui-même les
échecs c'est la vie il se projette
entièrement dans le jeu d'échecs et n'a
d'autres centres d'intérêt quasiment que
le jeu d'échecs dont 14 ans champion des
états unis déjà
donc ça c'est un bon c'est un très grand
résultat bien sûr mais les états unis à
l'époque nous sommes pas bien sur la
terre des déchets avec la terre des
chefs ça reste l'europe et surtout une
rss puisque on est déjà post guerre
mondiale on est à 58 quand il obtient
son titre de grand maître
et maintenant il faut qu'ils se lancent
à l'assaut du vraiment des échecs start
de l'europe oui de l'europe et puis des
tournois zone aux interzones où il va
rencontrer l'armada soviétique
parce que les soviétiques veulent bien
éventuellement se partager le titre
éventuellement un vol bien perdre mais
sûrement pas le perdre contre un
américain
oui encore - l'américain qui affiche
souvent un anticommunisme primaire de
bon aloi
puisqu'il considère que les soviétiques
sont des tricheurs qui joue en équipe ce
qui semble pas complètement faux il ya
eu cet incident à curaçao au tournoi de
qualification pour le championnat du
monde fin des années 50 début des années
60 où bobby fischer s'est plaint que les
soviétiques jouer entre guillemets en
équipe alors on peut qu'est ce que ça
veut dire jouer en équipe aux échecs
c'est simplement qu'il semblerait et
certaines études de chercheurs allemands
récentes tendent à le montrer que les
soviétiques en fait écourter leurs
partis volontairement quand ils se
rencontraient pour s'économiser faisait
une petite partie nulle de préparer à
l'avance et puis garder toute leur
énergie pour affronter fischer le
lendemain ou le surlendemain
ce qui fait que fisher était un petit
peu seul contre des gens qui s'entendait
pas ce que c'était un mode de
qualification par tout moment à partir
dans tous les sens une sorte de
mini-championnat comme on a au football
le championnat qu'on distingue de la
coupe
un couple ses face à face non mais là on
peut pas jouer avec les autres
partenaires il ya on est on est face à
l'adversaire est une et qui permet
d'éliminer celui qu'il ya une passe on
peut pas vraiment riche et et quand
c'est un championnat on peut imaginer
que certaines équipes entre elles
s'arrangent pour faire les résultats qui
finalement leur l'heure les avantages et
puis comme ça ils se renvoient un peu la
balle les uns les autres et donc ça
c'est au détriment de ceux qui essaient
de jouer fair play quand j'ai mangé pur
peut imaginer que si les autorités
soviétiques avaient dit que tel joueur
était celui qu'on devait aider
éventuellement certains ce jour
soviétique se sont couchés devant ses
joueurs pour leur laisser marquer le
point entier facilement à chaque ronde
un sens à l'histoire
difficile il est difficile de déterminer
si c'est absolument vrai ou pas mais en
tout cas on a des présomptions assez
forte communiqué officiel là dessus en
tout cas obi fisher et voit sa
progression un petit pas entravée par à
part ça il aura tout le monde imagine
dès la fin les années 50 qui va être
champion du monde
en tout cas on pense qu'il en a le
potentiel il va falloir qu'ils attendent
qu'ils se montrent patients
ils se hissent eric geste mais il se met
en opposition à ces règles parce que lui
il veut il ya des matches que des
confrontations directes parce que c'est
qu'on peut pas avoir d'arrangement
pendant ces compétitions direct il a
aussi un caractère assez fantasque
puisque jour où ils quittent l'interzone
halde dessous 167 alors qu'il est en
tête parce qu'il veut pas il veut pas
une ronde programmée le dimanche et il
veut pas jouer le dimanche pour des
raisons religieuses
donc voilà il ya des il ya des choses
qui sont assez marquante dans le
parcours de fisher parce que c'est
fondamentalement quelqu'un qui est
ingérable
c'est il est entièrement dans les échecs
et supporte pas la moindre contrariété
autour oui ici c'est justement c'est
cette volonté de
d'imposer qu'en 1960 son point de vue
qui va d'ailleurs non seulement de
porter ses fruits pour lui mais
transformer aussi le monde des échecs je
prends c'est ça qui est important parce
que il aura apporté comme classement
flore a dit plus tard finalement ce que
le un des grands apports de fischer
précise et le professionnalisme en
approche du jeu en sort du monde
dilettante avec fisher puisqu'il ya une
volonté vraiment de gagner qui dépasse
le simple fait de jouer qui va arriver
au delà de ça c'est une question
vraiment de commise et que fléchir son
plaisir aussi s'était brisé les golden
bears r oui donc ils sont
essentiellement de deux de plus grande
fierté ou de plus grand de ne plus
prendre intérêts dans le jeu c'était
quand y sentez comment donner légaux de
l'adversaire était détruit parce que
mais finalement il rencontre est plus
fort que lui qu'il fallait se rendre
courrier avec +2 et plus d' excuse est
possible la situation était assez
particulière jusque-là dans les échecs
puisqu'à partir de la seconde guerre
mondiale où après la seconde guerre
mondiale les soviétiques sont
professionnelles dans la mesure où mme
l'union soviétique l'état fait d'eux des
professionnels des sports les rémunère
et puis euh reverser les gains la
fédération russe des échecs mais en tout
cas ce sont des professionnels d'état
fischer lui elle peut être véritablement
le premier professionnel du jeu
individualiste wii du jeu et il va
effectivement aider à améliorer
grandement les conditions puisque sa
personnalité et ses succès et puis le
fait qu'ils soient américains attirent
beaucoup les médias ça attire des moyens
et les bourses pour les matches les
dotations pour les tournois augmentent
fortement dans la période de fisher et
après fischer donc alors cette histoire
de tournoi c'est ses points de vue donc
in fine ans il sort histoire du fiqh
lambris et il aime pause
une pression monde des échecs puisqu'on
a un joueur qui est très clairement
candidat au titre mondial qui finalement
ne participe pas ça dévalorise le cycle
ça dévalorise le titre de champion du
monde en montrant deux parties et donc
petit à petit finalement c'est la fille
des essais des ses hommes je crois qu'il
est à la tête de la file et à ce moment
là c'est vers l'ancien champion du monde
des années 30 qui est président de la la
fédération internationale fini par
accéder finalement à la demande de
fisher et transforme le championnat du
monde en ce qu'il aurait dû être
sans doute c'est à dire en cycle de
matches et non plus un cycle de tournoi
donc il faut alors quand même des
tournois de qualification pour vérifier
disons les meilleurs les 16 meilleurs ou
les 30 meilleurs plein porte mais après
ce sont des matches et il faut gagner
match par match pour arriver au grand
match la grande finale le championnat du
monde proprement dits contre le tenant
du titre donc là il ya plus de
possibilité de jouer en équipe
fischer a pas de problème à se hisser
dans les quinze meilleurs même avec des
joueurs qui s'arrangent entre eux mais
après alors en match c'est là qu'il va
pouvoir donner toute la mesure de son
talent mais peut-être qu'il aurait déjà
pu être champion demande des 69 c'est
vraisemblable c'est vraisemblable bon ça
on pourra jamais le savoir en tout cas
en 1971 72
il est encore très jeune il a 28 29 ans
quand il est sur moi presque à son
apogée
et quand ils se retrouvent qualifiés
pour les matches des candidats il va
donner toute la mesure de son talent et
même au delà puisque on croit qu'il va
avoir fort à faire avec bent larsen le
danois il le bat 6,06 ion on pense que
time and off en demi finale va lui
opposer une résistance farouche
le bas 6 0 dur sign of d'ailleurs de
croire qu un grave problème après près
ça parce que les autorités soviétiques
ont dit ya forcément une explication
politique et une telle défaite et ils
ont privé time and of de ses droits
civiques pour commencer si considéré
qu'il était nécessairement complice de
fisher entre pas perdre 6 0 en demi
finale des candidats puis en finale des
candidats
petrossian ancien champion du monde
connu pour être infranchissable
quasiment pour sa défense acharnée à
peyruis 6 2
puis vice champion du monde en titre et
gilles il n'a perdu qu'en 60 milliards
d'uc en 69 kg vice-champion du monde y
perd 6 à 2 donc là on se rend compte
quand même qu'on est face à quelqu'un
qui est au sommet de son art et le match
l'apogée c'est le match de 72 à
reykjavik contre boris spassky le match
pour le titre qui il a donné lieu voilà
une très nombreuse littérature et à de
très nombreux récits puisque ça fait
vraiment partie de la légende de bobby
fischer même la fischer menace de pas
venir jouer il doit imposer ses
conditions
deux jours avant le match on sait pas si
encore s'il va venir il a fallu que
mécène arrive pour dire mais moi je vais
rajouter des prix et c'est finalement ça
fait bouger fischer mais ça suffit pas
même pendant le match il va demander que
les journalistes soient pas dans la
salle de jouer à côté c'est parce qu'il
va accepter ces revendications puis
finalement plus que bien plus tard il
aura sans doute regretter d'avoir tout
accepter dû être un peu plus ferme
et puis finalement dans ce match et
quand même un magnifique match qui dure
longtemps parce que c'est le premier à
six parties en plus il a même posé ça on
est sorti deux des 24 parties
réglementaire et c'était le premier a
gagné six parties donc le match n'avait
potentiellement part de fans il finit
par gagner quand même assez clairement
puisque c'est 6 3 le score final si je
me souviens bien
et une victoire qui fait sans doute le
plus parler du jeu des chaires et que
sur toute la planète dans tout les
élèves de toute l'époque du jeu d'échecs
jamais il ya eu un championnat du monde
aussi couverts que cet affrontement
amérique russie paraît chez kia
interposé en pleine guerre froide en
pleine tension politique internationale
et ce symbole de la victoire d'un
américain oui le match était considéré
comme par les grands médias occidentaux
comme une sorte de guerre froide en
résumé une sorte de zoom sur la guerre
froide d'une certaine façon celui qui
déniait sur l'échiquier montrait lequel
le cas des deux systèmes étaient le plus
à même de favoriser l'éclosion de
l'intelligence et d'un homme nouveau et
de c'était un affrontement qui était
symbolique mais qui était extrêmement
important dans la guerre froide et qui
était considérée comme telle par les
autorités soviétiques pour qu'il n'était
pas question de perdre pour les
américains non plus du reste puisque
nixon adp s'est dépêché kissinger pour
aller retrouver bobby fischer quand il
avait disparu quelques jours avant le
match et il a envoyé un télégramme à
bobby fischer pour le dire vous êtes
défense le défenseur du monde libre ne
l'oublié pas vous êtes là pour faire
triompher le monde libre face à la
dictature soviétique et donc le rôle
imposé à fisher était et est assez
énorme
lui il était là pour josé chaque espace
qui aussi d'ailleurs les deux hommes se
respectent et je n'avais pas de
d'inimitié particulière mais ce match a
une connotation lui très très
particulière jamais les médias ce sont
autant intéressé un match de championnat
du monde
l'anecdote veut que beaucoup de journaux
d'ailleurs et envoyer des non
spécialistes sur place puisque n'avait
pas forcément dans chaque journal un
spécialiste des échecs et ça a donné
lieu à des compte-rendus quelques fois
cocasse puisque les comptes rendus des
partis par des gens qui ne savaient pas
jose sharks étaient
un petit peu amusant je crois que c'est
un spécialiste du droit des tribunaux
qui avaient été envoyés par les plus
grands journaux français pour
retranscrire les parties mais qui ne
savaient pas déplacer les pièces donc
c'est ça montre l intérêt manifeste est
très très très fort des médias notamment
aux états unis où les échecs sont
rentrés à la télé à ce moment-là tout à
fait donc il a aussi fit la une du
magazine time time comme on l'appelait
il avait dit le che semaine je prends
tout
j'ai plus le titre en tête mais il avait
foi aussi l'aveu la couverture de sports
de sinistrés qui dit la grande revue de
sport américaine
donc voilà on pouvait imaginer qu'après
72 et si fischer continuer à conserver
son titre
les échecs aurait une audience fabuleuse
parce que les américains commencent à
s'y intéresser réellement beaucoup
d'américains franchissent la porte des
clubs en blanc devenir eux aussi un
petit peu bobby fischer il ya une
émulation très très lente au devant de
l'échiquier à vos couleurs et chic et à
ce moment là la participation de fisher
a beaucoup d'émissions de télévision
ensuite de très grand public en plus
bobby fischer se targuer comme le plus
élégant du monde donc il peut il passait
très bien à télévision il était toujours
très beaux costumes et puis il y avait
beaucoup de paires de chaussures elle
était la légende veut qu'il était assez
obsessionnel autour des chaussures en
tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui passait
bien dans les médias
c'était entre guillemets un bon client
pour les médias aussi oui c'est vrai
donc on pouvait imaginer à partir de 72
que l'intérêt pour les médias seraient
croissant et que ça permettrait de
structurer les échecs et les
professionnaliser et celles à clarion
finalement la deuxième partie david
fisher ici le grand mystère
le grand mystère le grand désarroi la
légende aussi c'est l'argent c'est ça
qui contribuent à la grande légende de
fisher puisque après ce titre est devant
il revient de façon triomphale au
cyanure faut pas oublier que on ad on a
des encore des archives on peut le voir
on a beaucoup de photos de sam et de la
traversée de fisher dans l'ordre de
grandes avenues de mur je sais pas la
casser parce que j'y connais rien
mais on le voit sur sur sur une voiture
comme comme les astronautes qui ruine la
lune avec toute la foule autour entraîna
clamé le champion du monde américain qui
fait un retour triomphal
mais après 72 et bien fischer disparaît
totalement alors totalement de du
circuit professionnel d'échec il ne joue
plus sur le tournant on ne le voit plus
il disparaît on dit qu'il a rejoint une
secte
on a tout dit on a tous vieilli vantant
ses pas il
il n'a peut-être pt 1 pt c'est quoi en
fait c'est pas clair parce qu'on arrive
à 75 avec trois ans de silence radio
fish est rien karpov le nouveau là nous
le nouveau météo russes la machine à
gagner russe qui est là pour revenir
reprendre le titre affiche r il bien bas
le changement est en finale après avoir
éliminé spassky oui et c'est comme on
l'attend le match est organisé
je crois que tout est prêt pour attendre
mais que fisher viennent défendre son
titre dans sa carte mais il n'y a pas
rien oui s'il en est ce parce qu'il n'y
a pas de réponse alors que je crois que
les bourses proposées par les pays
organisateurs sont son énorme je crois
que les philippines propose 5 millions
de dollars pour pour pour le match 1 5
million de dollars en 1975 soit autant
dire 20 millions d'euros maintenant
c'est énorme
le match est organisé car prof a battu
cornouaille en finale des candidats
retransmis par la télé sont liés tic
toute l'union soviétique attend le match
revanche car paul fischer te permettrait
un l'urss de laver l'affront de 1972
mais de match revanche il n'y aura pas
bobby fischer ne donne plus signe de vie
la fidh et est obligé de réagir et le
destitue de son titre de champion du
monde
et de fait sur tapis vert car pop
devient championne voilà d'ailleurs son
rang et est sans doute le malheur de
perdre d'avoir obtenu ce titre sans
avoir à finalement combattu le champion
en titre mais ça c'est une autre
histoire qu'on racontera
dans l'émission consacrée à karpov mais
on voit bien que les joueurs sont liées
sans cette rencontre et finalement parce
par cette absence
il ya même les mêmes td td gens qui
courent sur sur internet dans le monde
des échecs que le match aurait vraiment
eu lieu en secret les spéculations
complètement fantasmatique mais qui ont
bien comprendre bien comprendre que le
la disparition de fisher je parlais de
rimbaud tout à l'heure où il crée un peu
équivalente à la disparition de rimbaud
avec le temps et elle a véritablement
marqué profondément le monde des échecs
parce que c'est l'arlésienne
y a pas un joueur qui n'est pas dit je
peux que la fischer allait revenir c'est
un peu comme elvis presley qui disparaît
il ya toujours des américains qui voient
église prestait tous les jours dans la
rue et qui disent il est encore vivant
oui alors c'est des différents vie car
on savait qu'ils étaient en vie on
savait bien qu'ayant les temps en temps
quand même
il faisait une émission de radio ici aux
philippines ici un peu ailleurs il y
avait des petites des petits passages de
fisher mais qui y parler notamment de
théories du complot d'ailleurs pas ce
qu'il en sera dans son discours il
parlait d'un complot mondial et parler
d'eux donc peut-être qu arriver à ce
niveau là je suis à peut-être eu un choc
intellectuelle fort arriver à ce titre
de championne qui finit dans l'abolition
de toute sa vie peut-être qu'ils
unification aussi psychologique va dire
qui me convient voyait rien après
d'accessible de plus haut que ça
finalement une traité d'intérêt
finalement à jouer alors ceci dit il est
quand même resté actif dans le monde des
échecs
même à distance et même en étant très
peu prolixe en paroles puisque notamment
c'est lui qui a mis au point la nouvelle
cadence de jeu qui ont été popularisées
dès les années 80 qu'on appelle la
cadence fisher et qui depuis devenu le
standard du échec c'est à dire que
maintenant on a une capitale tant de par
exemple deux heures par joueur et à
chaque coup en fait on rajoute du temps
alors ça peut être trente secondes c'est
pas trois secondes si ses limites ces
quelques cd seconde en 1 30 souvent
qu'un sport mais c'est un capital temps
qu'on rajoute ce qui évite de les
problèmes de perte sèche
autant on a toujours un petit capital
temps minimum puisque chaque plus on a
un petit rajout et ça c'est une
nouveauté qui a transformé la proche du
jeu puisque c'est maintenant adoptés par
tous c est rare que ça ne le soit plus
c'est d'autant plus facile avait dépendu
est venu sur ce n'était pas possible et
pendrel épandu mécanique mais c'est
fischer il ya proposé ça et qui qui a
popularisé 7,7 cette façon de joueur qui
ait eu alors qu'ils jouaient plus c'est
à dire qu'il était totalement absent il
a défendu ses droits pour son livre
aussi puisqu'il a parlé du fait que les
russes lui payer par le droit et au donc
s'occuper de l'argent ça c'est occuper
un peu et il revient alors là ça a été
alors pour moi vous n'avez pas mais
vraiment vécu dimanche 72 mais pendant
ça a été mon moment et chic est un de
mes moments et chicken est plus fort
puisqu'il revient 92e temps après il
réorganise un match fischer spassky 1,92
à l'évidence à moins d'impact que celui
sans nous mais quand même beaucoup c'est
à dire que l'ennemi ce match a fait plus
parler encore des échecs dans le monde
des médias en richesse je dirais que les
grands matchs kasparov et karpov ou au
moins longtemps en tout cas ils ont
autant c'est vrai que c'est une drôle
d'idée d'organiser un match revanche 20
ans après dans une ancienne yougoslavie
est sous embargo américain puisque leur
en ai plein de guerre de yougoslavie
c'est une drôle d'idée mais pas si drôle
dans l'idée dans l'esprit de fisher
parce qu'ils considèrent qu'il est
toujours champion du monde le fait
d'avoir été destituée de son titre en
1975 le considère comme une décision
nulle et non avenue
le congrès américain lui-même en 1986
fait voter une motion pour stipuler que
bobby fischer est bien toujours champion
du monde de val d'isère et c'est
extraordinaire la décision de la fis des
pour une décision qui n'a aucun sens
bobby fischer a été empêché de défendre
son titre et considère donc que il ya eu
un il ya eu une vacuité il ya une
vacance de pouvoir entre 72 et 92 et que
pour renouer le fil
il faut refaire match contre spassky
conception assez étrange c'est que ce
parce qu'à ce moment là et est classé
dans le nom de merlan loin parce qu'il
doit être dans les 30 ou 40
oui oui sur les mondiaux parmi les
secours à coup moins actif que dans les
années soixante dix et il est parti en
france
il était si les partis l'union
soviétique il joue beaucoup moins donc
c'est pas non plus le plus l'adversaire
le plus le plus coriace que fisher
pouvait se trouver mais c'était une
façon de renouer le fil avec 1972
fischer gagne aussi ce match higgins
macarons d'ailleurs clairement y avait
des mails parti c'est pas ce n'était pas
un match bidon meyers a joué comme il y
avait deux une belle conception je me
rappelle aussi des analyses qui étaient
autour du maintien on voulait absolument
analyser le jeu de fisher est ce qu'il
est aussi fort qu'avant mais il n'était
pas si mauvais que ça sert d'ailleurs si
on calculait le lots de fisher sur ce
match par rapport au classement de ce
parce qu'ils étaient à 2600 à peu près
bon moins qu'elle
sa grande époque mais quand même
toujours très fort on retrouve un
classement de ces chers qui l'aurait
placé dans les tous premiers mondiaux
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire aussi
c'est à dire que même sans avoir joué en
tout cas de façon officielle et bien par
dont il avait toujours maintenu son
niveau de jouer alors la légende deux
autres légendes des années 90 on a
souvent vu aussi apparaître bobby
fischer sur internet c'est à dire que
beaucoup de joueurs sur les ondes de jeu
10 voilà j'ai joué contre bobby fischer
s'est notamment short tee shirt short
maillot le short plus grands champions
anglais qui a fait partie des cafés une
finale de championnat se passe par an
c'est une porte qui déclare qu'il est
quasi sûr qu'un joueur qui qui donnait
pas son nom et chippis quel nom il avait
d'ailleurs enfin le pseudo quelconque
médiane donnait pas son nom mais vu le
style qu'il avait de jouer tout et qu'il
avait échangé quelques mots avec lui en
lui demandant notamment
qu'est ce qui s'est passé at-elle tourné
en 1962 on truque que seuls fischer
pouvait savoir et le mec a répondu donc
il s'est dit possible que ce soit
fischer voilà bon et alors si cher
continue à avoir quelques petites
réactions d'entendre notamment il a dit
que l'image qu'un prof kasparov était
truqué des strokes a donc quelques
petites passages radio qu'on peut
retrouver sur internet alors on peut
retrouver quelques-uns de ses passages
la grande histoire de fisher capturé au
japon par les etats-unis à la fin voilà
ce que si c'est la fin oui là c'est à
partir de 92 c'est un peu la descente
aux enfers parce que il a joué en
yougoslavie alors qu'elle était sous
embargo américain
si il ya eu bien sûr une bourse pour ce
match donc il ya une relation
commerciale hors tout acte commercial
était interdit par les eaux américaines
donc il est donc suivi se retrouve hors
la loi il se retrouve poursuivi par les
autorités américaines ironie de
l'histoire pour quelqu'un qui a reçu un
télégramme de nixon lui disant qu'il
était le défenseur du monde libre
maintenant c'est lui qu'on poursuit donc
ce qui renforce vraiment la paranoïa et
la théorie du complot chez fischer
ensuite il se commet à 2
plusieurs reprises dans des déclarations
très malheureuse il se réjouit des
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 il
s'enfuit au japon il s'est fini par se
fuir en islande qui lui offre l'asile
alors au japon pour raconter l'histoire
c'est là qu'il est au japon à ce moment
là apparemment il s'est marié avec la
présidente de la fédération japonaise
des chèques louis je sais pas trop quoi
quelque chose comme ça mais enfin c'est
je sais pas enfin je suis assez loin
comme ça il faut pas qu'hambourg laisse
mais il se fait arrêter au japon et les
etats unis demandent son extradition en
fait visiter pourriez demander bon alors
ce sens nous pas à 100 je peux je suis
pas sûr qu'il soit arrivé l'an chose si
les termes états unis mais c'est quand
même la justice alors ils les procédures
etc
et puis finalement ce qui se passe c'est
que pour sortir de cette affaire est
bien de l'islande où il avait finalement
commis son plus grand succès son plus
grand triomphe en 72 lui propose
devenir 2 impasse port ici on est en
train de devenir en islande et
finalement donc il extradé en islande et
non pas aux états unis et c'est la
finance qui meurt peu de temps après
finalement oui il meurt en 2008 64 ans
64 c'est le nombre de cases de
l'échiquier
c'est oui ça semble anecdotique mais
c'est pas le seul champion du monde avec
man à 64 ans là la fin de sa vie il
semble un peu pathétique d'après d'après
ce qu'on a ce qu'on peut voir sur
certains documentaires qui essayent de
retracer sa vie ou qui essayait de
retrouver sa trace
à la fin de la fin de sa vie c'est un
sternum musée par mu rechute qui peut à
qui n'a plus grand chose à dire sur les
échecs et qui est qui se commet encore
en souvent déclarations malheureuses
ici c'est plus c'est plus que l'ombre de
lui-même c'est plus que l'ombre du jeune
homme élégant qui qui a fait rêver
l'occident qui a fait rêver le monde
entier même
alors voilà c'est le grand mystère
fischer qui restera à éclaircir je pense
qu'on n'a pas fini d'étudier à vide
fisheye ya sans doute des documents qui
traîne et qu'on n'a pas encore dont on
n'a pas encore connaissance il va
falloir peut-être plus tard découvrir un
peu plus précisément ce qui s'est passé
dans cette période 1972-2008 finalement
on a peu d'informations par ce match le
match retour de 92 alors quelques images
maintenant de bobby fischer avant de
passer à la partie du jour une des
belles parties de poppy fischer ici
fischer donc jeunes en train de
réfléchir son échiquier or c'est une vue
de près de la photo suivante puisque
regarder voilà alors les magnifiques
photos documents c'est un vrai document
puisque c'est fischer face à michaël
talent c'est quand même pas rien alors
hier on parlait dans une autre émission
parler de daisy chantier en carton ou en
vinyle des olympiades de malte là on a
une très belle table avec échiquier
incrusté est magnifique c'est une langue
magnifique cette photo c'est un vrai
tournoi d'échecs avec lui on voit le
public est derrière
on voit un joueur qui est penché sur
l'échiquier derrière où je sais pas si
c'est pas l'heure me trouvant peu
importe la pendule l'ancien les
anciennes étant d'une mécanique derrière
voilà leur belle pendule lebel échiquier
sur lesquels ils sont les feuilles de
partie avec le stylo enfin c'est
vraiment là ces photos classiques est
aussi très esthétique voilà on est on
est convié mais on et cravate est on est
on est bien quoi faire adorer les
costumes et en face de lui il ya michael
talent qui à l'époque est champion du
monde et qui est connu pour son style
fait de sacrifices
éblouissant donc les affrontements entre
les deux étaient souvent explosif
c'était extraordinaire les parties
fischer leuthard le fischertal sont
vraiment superbe brune un ami dans son
livre qui est son best-seller absolu il
faut absolument avoir lu mes soixante
meilleur parti de bobby fischer c'est
quand même un sommet de la littérature
égyptienne
c'est c'est le pro un des premiers
champions où le premier champion qui est
vraiment analyser ses propres parties
avec un peu plus d'objectivité possible
au point d'avoir mis des deux des partis
amis où il a perdu le crd défaite ça
c'est rare qu'un canard quand même je
crois qu'il y en a deux oui non mais
c'est rare mais des joueurs qui mettent
leur défaite dans leur vie et demi des
nuls aussi les parties nulles bon il a
fait il a montré qu'il était capable de
juger son jeu avec objectivité et non
pas un essayant de se valoriser
donc c'était c'était vraiment dans ses
rangs un sommet la littérature et
chicken voilà fischer contre talent très
belles photos absolument avoir un poster
chez soi si on aime les échecs et voilà
alors ça c'est alors qu'est ce que c'est
que cette photo tu nous a mis une photo
la jirs sommes un peu un peu inédite
appelée ds que des photos de fisher il y
en a des centaines évidemment ouais mais
c'est l'église en i stand à côté de
laquelle bobby fischer a été enterré
tout simplement en 2008 voir elle semble
perdue au milieu de la campagne donc
pour quelqu'un qui a été au centre de
l'attention mondiale
finalement je pense qu' on peut dire
qu'ils reposent en paix et qui est
libéré de ses de ses démons intérieurs
ouais c'est symbolique de voir comme ça
une petite église tout tout seul en fait
l'un des trésors c'était cette église là
donc là où repose beaucoup fischer qui
est quand même fait partie finalement
d'aider des hommes les plus qu'ils
restent les plus connus de la planète je
n'avais rien pas parmi les joueurs
d'échecs c'est sans doute le plus connu
mais voilà il est en islande dans un
petit pays perdu il à côté d'une toute
petite église mairie
voilà la tombe de bobby fischer ici on
tombe elle même très très très simple
très très humble robert james fischer
mars me sanson 43 ans lit parfaitement
janvier 2008 continue ici on le voie
d'eau les sens
sûrement turbulent comme il pouvait
l'être en classe donc sans doute à new
york new york en train d'analyser une
partie en fait celui ci travaille à
l'entraînement en fait avec son
entraîneur
donc il a tu me dises et collins collins
et on va voir sur votre photo / photo
sion toujours collins et puis lombardie
qu'on connaît mieux
qui est qui a fait partie de l'entourage
de fisher et qui a qui a écrit aussi et
qui était un champion américaine on se
moque j'aurais vraiment est toujours à
new york et là c'est donc ces fichiers
en train de s'entraîner avec avec ses
collègues
alors il faut il plus fort que déjà
voilà donc on va revenir ce plateau et
on va passer maintenant sans plus tarder
à une magnifique partie debout si cher
en fait c'est une partie qui est
l'oppose à victor cochonneries alors une
victoire qui tendait encore
encore jeune qui commence à devenir
parent qui n'est pas encore le violeur
le vieux l'union qu'on peut encore nommé
comme ainsi aujourd'hui en 2012 qui est
toujours actif mais c'est le cornouaille
encore jeunes de lyon lionceaux à 70 bis
qui n'arrivera en finale des
championnats du monde que huit ans plus
tard le grand victor kornoi et il
affronte ici dont fischer en 1970 dans
un tournoi de blitz
oui aimé cette partie n'est pas resté
dans les bases de données par hasard
parce que malgré que ce sont 8 cm c'est
une magnifique partie va voir elle est
superbe et elle est typique du style de
fisher puisque ça fait partie de ces
grandes attaques de type estonienne donc
que les grands joueurs
l'attak doivent connaître pour savoir
comment comment traiter ce genre de
position alors on y va à l'école mais
qui démarre avec le coût des quatre
cavaliers m6 de fisher ses 4 et 6 et a
pris car les c3 fou j'ai sept
on a la structure est indienne ici le
fou qui s'est développé ce qu'on appelle
en fion qu'eto'o on prépare le rock et
on a une action évidemment sur la grande
diagonale on laisse les blancs ici
occuper le centre
oui on laisse les blancs occuper le
centre ça pourrait sembler un peu
paradoxal on se dit que c'est une drôle
idée de laisser aux blancs le privilège
du centre mais occuper le centre et le
contrôle et sont deux choses un petit
peu différente on voit quand même que le
fou g7 et cavaliers m6 sur une action
sur le centre même si un petit peu plus
un petit peu plus lointaine et puis
surtout on va laisser aux blancs la
responsabilité du centre et essayé de
faire exploser ce centre par des
attaques de pions latéraux par exemple
ces cinq voire f5 un petit peu plus tard
alors on y va donc avec eux quatre des
six donc là on contiennent avec le plus
de 6 on contient d'avancé aux siens on
prépare les avancées e5 les avancées ces
cinq éventuellement pour commencer à
contre attaquer au centre fouet deux
tout ça est normal tout c'est bien connu
petit roch carrier f3 et là ça y est le
5 c'est un choix déjà responsable il ya
d'autres coups possibles mais 5 est sans
doute le plus agressif dans cette
position alors le petit ensemble aux
prises sauf que en fait après
alors c'est des variantes possibles on
peut prendre ici avec les blancs et
après la reprise on peut échanger les
dames prise prises et lecavalier
pourrait se dire on peut prendre ici 1,5
sauf que en fait la pression sur le pion
aux 4 est déjà forte avec le cavalier et
le fou pourrait prendre le cavalier ici
à revers après que le câble et noirs et
prix en le cas donc ce genre de manip
explique pourquoi les blancs rentre pas
dans cet échange qui ont final on passe
à il ya des subtilités on peut aussi
attaquer avec la tour etc
mais le centre-nord blanc est tellement
sous pression que la finale qui en
résultent puisqu'on a échoué les dames
et finalement une finale qui va mener
rapidement une égalisation noir dans un
premier temps et pourquoi pas après les
prises davantage donc les blancs préfère
garder un petit avantage est de garder
l'attention au centre petit rock le coup
suivant est le coup le plus logique le
plus agressif
on sort le cavalier très vite on rajoute
de la pression sur le pion des cas qui
est déjà attaqué les pions et en même
temps on protège aussi le cinglant
compteur laprise mêmes seraient punis
directement paris sans doute la prise
même du cavalier avec une égalité rapide
on invite de façon un peu preuve quand
on invite des blancs a poussé le pion
des andes et 5 pour attaquer le cavalier
bien sûr mais ça va fixer la structure
blanche au centre et ça va là ça va en
faire une cible
ça va permettre de l'ateq exact tout à
fait c'est à dire qu'après est donc
maintenant des 5 et cavaliers sept
voiliers que les noirs ont d'abord leur
came liste quand même développé lui
quand même le sel ont fixé quand tu lis
effectivement la chaîne de clients qui
est en un briquet sur celle des noirs
donc des coûts de libération de type est
maintenant sont possibles sur l'ale
parce que quand le centre est bloqué on
peut commencer à attaquer la base on
veut bien qu'ici si la base de la
mini-chaîne d'options ici donc c'est
cette base qu'il faut attaquer donc le
coin f5 et à l'ordre du jour il va
falloir d'abord sortir ce cavalier f6
peut-être en décèdent
pourquoi pas en 1 8 pardon ici à 8 sur
l'une de ses deux cases et après on
pousse l5 les ont tués entre défendre
lyon on augmente la pression sur le pion
aux 4 et ainsi on développe notre
initiative les droits puisque c'est ici
qu'on a notre masse de pièces et on veut
pourquoi pas lancer une attaque est allé
créer des menaces contre le roi blanc le
plan des blancs eux regarder la chaîne
de pions ici regarde
de ce côté là quand la chaîne de pions
noirs regarde de ce côté là vous voyez
comment c'est extrêmement clair la base
des pions noirs est ici et les blancs
peuvent ouvrir le jeu allèles dame par
des cons comme b4 des coups comme ces
cinq essayé de faire pression sur des
six ouvrir ici emprise et ensuite en
mettant les tours sur les colonnes
notamment la colonne c'est ici bien sûr
et bien créé notre potentiel d'invasion
dans le camp ennemi c'est le plan des
blancs attaquer les lames ça va aller
assez vite aussi l'énorme avantage ici
que si leur attaque passe c'est que
c'est le roi qui visait donc il y aura
des échecs alors que là il y aura pas
d'échec mais souvent si le problème
c'est que l' attaquent parfois les dames
pas plus vite que l'attak aller loin et
la différence matérielle fait la
différence
donc quand je menais continue par un
coup logique ici qu'à l'aller 2-2 il
anticipe la prochaine poussée m5 ici
parce que en d2 mais on protège le 4 et
puis pourquoi pas dans certaines
possibilités on peut jouer f3 qui
protège aussi ici et ce cavalier aussi
plus tard quand on a joué des cas
peuvent venir en b3 et soutenir la
poussée c5 et après ces cinq qui pourra
peut-être même venir s'installer en c4
et après éventuellement on ne vient pas
enlever trois ont poussé 5 éventuel ce
cavalier bien sûr aussi peuvent venir
sur la case c4 et augmenté la pression
sur le pion des six qui sera en prise du
pion du cavalier et pourquoi pas plus
tard même du fou qui vient à 3 donc
voyez que comment les blancs peuvent
forcer aussi des noirs à prendre ces
cinq alors là par contre ça leur crée
une mariée le pion très forte vers vers
le centre et vers le camp le camp n'aura
donc ici un coup logique dans cette
position qu'il faut comprendre et
connaître le coût de fisher était tout à
fait intéressant c'est le coup c'est 5
voilà le coup de fisher l'idée fischer
s'est de l'irb écoute j'ai bien compris
tu veux jouer c c et c
je joue un coup préventif de ce côté là
avant de lancer mon attaque à la loi
parce que je bloque
ici la position ça sera plus dur pour
toi de pousser b4y situe d'abord tout de
suite on peut pas le faire
les lots km et en l'air donc il va
falloir jouer des coups comme à troyes
déco combien tout ça est l'enjeu peut
protéger par v6 et c'est plus dur pour
les blancs de trouver une pénétration du
côté du côté dames sur cette structure
là si les blancs prennent en c6 ce qui
est possible
on reprend en passant ici prise en
passant puisqu'on vient de jouer c'est
celle qu'on peut le faire uniquement le
coup d'après donc faut le faire
maintenant
elle y allaient nous reprendre et du
pion b et attention c'est les noirs
maintenant qu'ils auraient une majorité
de pions centraux trois pions contre
uniquement de avec la possibilité de se
libérer plus tard par le coût des 5
surtout qu'on a déjà deux cavaliers qui
protège le dessin avec une égalité
rapide voire prise davantage rapide donc
c'est hors de question donc à trois
corners je sens que le coup le plus
immédiat est le coup le plus logique et
sans doute le coup qu'il faut jouer dans
cette position à 3
l'idée c'est pas temps de protéger sa
que de préparer des quatre pour
poursuivre le plan et l'afficheur ne
perd pas de temps il faut pas perdre de
temps ici à jouer des coups passif il
faut très vite attaqué cavaliers 8
alors ça pas l'air d'être un coup de
tête mais c'est un coup d'état qui s'est
un coup d' attaque il a deux intérêts
secousses et que je protège des six ça
peut être utile parfois parce que sur
cavaliers ici je veux toujours en
attaque et ça donc ça obligerait la dame
à rester ici mais cette dame elle a
envie tôt ou tard devenir son âge 4 soit
éventuellement g5
donc c'est bien avant le travail en
défense ça peut être utile mais surtout
je libère la possibilité de jouer une
scène qu'on avait ni total donc d4
quand même cornouailles ne perd pas de
temps attention il ya une vraie menace
tout de suite parce que surprise prise
eh bien on a un pion passer ici ça peut
s'avérer
extrêmement pénible donc fischer joue le
coup suivant b6 tout à fait possible
alors on peut envisager aussi de laisser
la prise parce que tant que le cavalier
là vous faites après prise prison peut
envisager après de mettre le corps ayant
des six il y pas mal ce cavalier parce
que il devient un bloqueur de dessins et
puis ils attaquent le pion aux 4 et il
attaque le pion ses cadres donc ça peut
être aussi une idée de le laisser
prendre
c'est toujours embêtant de laisser
l'adversaire se crée un pion passé mais
si on arrive à mettre un cavalier de
vent qui est très mobile et qui peut
aller vers l'avant vers l'arrière sur
les côtés revenir sur cette case de
blocage on minimise largement le
désavantage du pion passé à douala mais
le fisher lui peut choisir quand même de
surprotéger c5 afin d'éviter cette cette
année tombe rien de cornouaille paraît
logique puisque après pions prendre puis
on prend et bien on a une colonne
ouverte ceci dit une fois qu'on a dit ça
ne s'est pas trop et c'est sans doute là
où pêchent la stratégie de course folle
sur ce qu ont quand même on sait pas
trop ce qu'on va faire sur cette colonne
parce que souvent sur le côlon c'est bon
on voit qu'on peut venir ans s est ici
mais si c'est dur parce que l'on
baissait thiel fou ce fou et d'en rester
là jusqu'à la fin de la partie
en général on dit que dans les stades
yens quand ce fou bouge c'est pour faire
maths
donc en général et des restes là
pourquoi parce qu'il est à la fois
défensives bien sûr mais aussi surtout
offensifs et tôt ou tard c'est un fou
qui vient faire un échec mortels ou qui
veulent contrôler des cases mortelle du
côté roy donc il a une action regarder
magnifique 1 se fout et souvent il bouge
pas c'est sa meilleure case en fait donc
on voit pas trop comment protéger enfin
pénétrer sur cette colonne c'est
difficile même si un cavalier vient ici
on voit pas trop il peut pas avancer
imbéciles ici la casse v6 est protégé
par le pion bref on valoir qu'il aura du
mal à trouver son attaque alors f5 et
fisher lui continue son attaque est
attaqué voilà peut-être que il fallait
trouver pour construire quelque chose
peut-être commencé à jouer à 4 à 5 alors
ici quand on choisit un coup
on peut critiquer cf3 qui paraît logique
on voit souvent cette structure de pion
dans l'espagne elle le problème de f3
c'est que je bouge l'action de fouda mi6
qui est quand même bien pratique pour
empêcher des velléités de jouer j'ai 5 h
5 puisqu'il est le premier pion h5 sera
un prix on contrôle aussi très bien la
casse g4 c'est pas facile d'avancer
contrecoup d'un messi avait le pion
c'est plus facile on ne peut jouer à 5
en plus jouer j 5 g 4 oui donc c'est
plus dur parce que c'est plus facile le
plan f3 en quelque sorte offre une cible
il ya quelque chose allait mordre
allaient attaquer dans le hall of fame
si il offre une scie exactement tout à
fait il a faibli
finalement cette diagonale c'est quand
même pas rien non plus sachant que si ce
fou se réveille un jour ben petit échec
là sera pénible qu'on a le roi sera
obligé d'aller là où il a pas envie
d'aller totalement dans le coin sous le
feu des pièces noires éventuellement et
enfin si blanc prennent ans le 4 on
reprend pas de pions on comprend en
général plutôt du cavalier donc c'est là
que finalement on se dit que ce coût
était le cookie un peu léger d'ailleurs
à noter que moi j'ai vu une partie
kasparov un corner kasparov au corps à
corps avec les blancs dans les années 90
au trophée bompard en partie rapide donc
c'est beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
tard que cette partie et on est à plus
de vingt ans d'écart et bien encore ce
nom il a évité pendant toute la partie
de bouger les pions de son effroi et
kasparov qui était aussi un grand
attaquant est indienne dans la lignée de
bobby fischer on peut dire que kasparov
et un des héritiers de fisher sans
conteste il attaque et aussi avec
l'estonienne dans ces années là et bien
à cette partie il a essayé de pousser
les pions poussé poussé mais comme les
nuls ou blancs et pas jouer il n'a
jamais réussi à percer en attendant la
l'initiative de torchon était-elle de
l'autre côté qu'il a dû rebrousser
chemin rapatrier toutes ces pièces en
défense et
il s'en est fallu deux cheveux qui
perdent cette partie qui s'est terminée
par une partie nulle
donc on voit bien quand je n'en ai
appris sans doute le sont finalement de
cette partie à vingt ans d'écart f4
maintenant de fisher voilà maintenant qu
on peut jouer quatre puisque les
finances les blancs se sont affaiblis
ils ont même perdu un coup de pions en
plus on prend la case 3 donc c'est fini
on pourra plus jamais pu jouer au foot
croirait parfois les pratiques se font
le 3 parce qu'il peut revenir en défense
quand le roi est venu arracher un pour
venir en ga ça arrive souvent
là c'est fini pour apa ce sera beaucoup
plus long il peut le faire mais alors il
faut qu'il reste par des deux il faudra
tirer tout ça et surtout maintenant je
prépare jeu complètement bloqué les
chaînes de pions et je prépare la
poussée g5 h5 pourquoi parages et 4 et
puis enfin g3 avec matin rapide annonce
et s'enferme le fou g7 mais c'est pas le
fou le plus le plus actif dans cette
position donc de toutes façons le pion
cinq blocs le fou g7 depuis quelques
coups tu as face et pas efficace qui
change grand chose à la faire alors
continuons à lui continue son idéal elle
dame et joue à quatre semaines en b 4
est protégé par un tour donc ya pas de
problème en cas de bris et je vois
quatre il veut affaiblir l dame
il veut jouer à cinq qui veut prendre un
v6 il veut prendre ses seins qui veut
essayer d'ouvrir le jeu est là les dames
c'est logique et la salle et le plan de
fisher il a une il y est d'une clarté
d'une habilité absolue alors j'ai
s'inquiètent plusieurs intérêts bien sûr
qu'on a dit il ya une cible à les viser
en f3 donc pourquoi pas préparé la
poussée h 5 puis j'ai 4 puis j'ai 3 1
puis j'ai sali n'est parce qu'un projet
doit imaginer ce cavalier bouge on a
joué 20 matches 4 ans menace maths et
quand les blancs jouent h3c là où le fou
ces huit là tout son intérêt pour aller
se sacrifier fermathe et le deuxième
intérêt de ce coût ce qui permet
éventuellement de faire monter la tour
en m6 et puis de la faire coulisser
angers 6 ans un schisme voilà ça c'est
le désir en libère la la troisième ici
la sixième en lui et où la troisième
pour les blancs c'est pour faire
circuler les pièces courtes sur sur
cette rangée en lice laurent dernière et
on circule et on a une pièce tourne en
soutien de l'avancée des fantassins et
c'est extrêmement puissants en général à
5 de cornouaille là aussi c'est
conséquent il continue son plan malgré
tout donc
donc il joue à 5 il veut essayer
d'ouvrir au maximum c'est pas simple
c'est pas clair
c'est pas simple de savoir comment
ouvrir cette position donc tout riffs 6
à l'oreille c'est ce que tu disais alors
double intérêt de 70 6 tab surprotège
des six ce qui peut avoir du sens aussi
faut pas oublier en cas d' échange
généralisé on peut envisager de
reprendre du piano et pourquoi pas un
mot sur contrôler la casse des six ça
peut aider
et puis bon ben voilà on veut se mettre
ici pour aider à la pousser un bébé
prend cscec normal de contenants des
princes et scène donc il est finalement
on se demande pourquoi il jouer à 4 à 5
parce que et il aurait pu prendre un b 6
aussi mais ça aurait ouvert finalement
la cofrac pour la tour il s'est rendu
compte peut-être que non et que c'était
pas forcément à son avantage et la
caraïbe et 3 bon alors qu'à l'e3
pourquoi pas bon ça on se demande juste
un peu ouverte et valier après c'est ça
qu'il avait pris la limite ici prise
prise il aurait au moins essayer
peut-être plus tard d'aller sur la casa
5 et venir ensuite sur la case c6 mais
là il peut pas venir tout de suite bon
un autre intérêt pour ça peut être de
jouer ça c'est lent mais ça peut être
utile et même nécessaire notamment de
pour empêcher plus tarder damage 4 1
c'est à dire que c'est le fou qui
contrôlent pas céder ronald c il est
totalement mort se font pour l'instant
on voit pas comment briser maintenant ce
mur c'est que les coûts de confinement
ils sont un peu sont un peu
stéréotypes et de ce côté là et donc
peut-être un peu de précision
donc j'ai 6 ans fischer lui apprécié par
contre tours g6 et maintenant ils se
préparent donc on voit bien que ça
commence à sentir le roussi pour laurent
blanc
ces langues mais les positions fermes et
on n'est pas pressé il faut et suffit
ici il faut il suffit de jouer des coups
forts dans l'optique de continuer son
attaque
c'est lent mais c'est précis on sait ce
qu'il va faire et on a l'impression que
pas grand chose à faire contre il n'ya
pas faire ça donc tous des deux voilà
c'est l'idée tél on en revient à foug d2
avec peut-être l'idée de venir en épi
d'empêcher des pénétrations forte kalyev
6 alors ça c'est leur maintenance autres
cavaliers a laissé passer le pion f
bon il a fini son travail bon il n'y a
pas eu d'attaqués de toutes façons de
contrôler décide donc de toute façon il
peut revenir ici et puis en venant ici
il a deux idées il peut ainsi aider à la
poussée g4 et pourquoi pas aussi dans
d'autres variantes
quand on joue g3 il peut parfois aussi
venir ensuite en scène qui est reprendre
du contrôle sur les classements ouachin
donc hors jeu noël comment ces voiliers
et commence à avoir peur d'un pouce et
trois chiens et la filière papa de temps
tout de suite il joue g4 donc il sait
aussi fischer que les temps compte
beaucoup d'échecs il faut pas perdre de
temps je pense que l'afficheur sait déjà
qu'il est dans son élément
c'est le roi des attaques estonienne il
joue g4 donc ça veut dire qu'il a estimé
que c'était le moment de prendre
avantage alors attention les menaces de
g4 ça peut être très vite de jouer chez
3 parce que le coût h3 peut être puni
très vite par des coups comme cavalier
h5 et aux menaces france 3 en cas de
prise et bien il ya g2
protégé par la tour et ses échecs avec
un de la tour et demi et une grosse
grosse attaque de même sans jouer
cavalier h5 du reste un tué et on peut
le jouer direct après h3 après j'ai 3 h
trois fous prend tout à fait après j'ai
trois ans qu'à 2 h 3 on peut aussi jouer
au fou pranger deux ans j'ai tout à fait
mais parfois aussi bien aux films et aux
cavaliers
selon les coups défensifs donc ici est
franche et 4 et simplement fischer
regarder bouge toujours pas s'en fout
qui et c'est sa meilleure occasion il ne
sort que pour permettre cavale et
pranger 4 c'est chaud évidemment il ya
attaque sur h4 ça fait peur ça fait très
très peur parce que la dame n'est pas
loin de pouvoir venir en h4
on peut toujours envisager même pourquoi
pas des sacrifices sur des 5 de ce
cavalier pour libérer l'action de la
dame et ça peut faire très vite mat
imaginons un coup passif des blancs je
sais pas beaucoup comme elle est calée à
80 donc juste pour analyser ce qui peut
se passer
imaginons le coup cavaliers à 4 aussi
pour voir comment la position pourrait
pourrait continuer on pourrait imaginer
une
une possibilité ici de faire un cavalier
prend h 40 par exemple et en cas de
prise en charge de on peut imaginer en
gare des cars à les prendre et 5
c'est très fort parce que regarder
damache 4 mon à ces chèques la tour
pourrait éventuellement sur sacrifier là
et il peut y avoir au moins un échec
perpétuelle de la dame
sans compter toutes les menaces
d'attaqués et les menaces de maths
donc c'est très très dangereux donc
c'est pour ça que après qu'à l'étranger
quatre corps jeune homme joue un coup de
défense qui devient essentiel ils jouent
tous resteront en touche 3 à plusieurs
intéressés que je contrôlais troisième
rangée donc déjà en cas d' en cas
d'échec peut envisager de sacrifier la
tour de maître la tomate 3 j'empêche des
pénétrations aussi du fou pourquoi pas
et puis aussi je peux mettre la dame en
défense par contre il faut bien laisser
de la tour sur la colonne f parce que
sinon un cavalier deux échecs fourchette
royal donc la tour et quand même doit
quand même avoir un oeil sur f2 toujours
tout à fait donc ici on joue tour à 6 11
jan fischer jouent tour à six y menacent
tout simplement gagne du pion avec une
attaque énorme donc il faut faire
quelque chose et c'est là qu'ils jouent
que corchia je dois je croire le
pointage 3 en clair c'est que regarder
on se met finalement en face du fou et
se fout ils rêvent que de ça de
sacrifier un jour ou l'autre contre la
défense du roi noir donc la voyais que
la position de plus en plus chaude la
pression monte
fischer est dans son élément corse non
il n'a pas réussi ici finalement à créer
de menaces
de pénétration dans le corps d'anne n'y
a rien de clair ici pour pour
cornouaille et il a peu de caisse en
défense il a quand même cinq pièces
allèles dame exactement de ses
personnels nam mais voilà sans avoir
réussi à percer alors que les pièces
noires vous allez voir regarder le coup
suivant de fléchir calais g6 c'est clair
un grand maine encore plus de pièces
regardez-le attaque
éventuellement il peut menacer devenir
pourquoi pas un lâche 4 attaquants
latour attaquant le pion g2 il peut y
avoir des sacrifices très rapide aussi
et puis regardez après roy g1 ils
commencent à se dire aïe aïe aïe je suis
face à la tour ou en devenir en juin
c'est bien parce que on peut pas venir
tout de suite angers 6 donc ils
s'attaquent lecavalier et puis
maintenant le cavalier est attaqué alors
que le pion été cloué donc là on
pourrait prendre le car les câpres
essayé de fuir avec loin quitte à donner
une pièce au passage pour éviter des
maths mais il peut il espère peut-être
que fisher prendre elle annule ici parce
que par exemple par dame d'un match 4
noir jouent des matches 4 ici clé dans l
lecavalier il ya échec alors si on fait
d'un match 4 ici par exemple on peut
imaginer puis on prend deux cavaliers et
puis échec roi f2 et puis une sucre
habituelles voilà voilà ce qui
arrangerait franchement il parce que là
il voit pas trop comment faire puisque
cinq en défense quand on n'est qu'en
défense évidemment là nul ça ne
s'arrange avait donc ici ben non mais
fisher ne doit pas la nuit c'est pas son
truc donc fyfe il fait cavalier et 6,6
hors de l'attaqué regarder la manoeuvre
qui va suivre derrière elle est
magnifique fouet un don c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure vous voyez tout ça
est très lent mais ça finit par arriver
en mettant le fou loeb et on empêche
maintenant une pénétration ultérieure de
la dame
mais regardez il a vu encore plus me
fichais regarder ces c'est joli c'est
quand même un scientifique de
l'estonienne kaia suite ça c'est pas mal
c'est un coup d'attaqué c'est paradoxal
c'est un coup d'attaqué alors l'idée de
cavaliers h 8 en fait pour fisher c'est
de recycler son cavalier en
fct maintenant j'ai 5 profitant de h3k
été jouée par les blancs puisque on va
attaquer la tour on a le fou prêt à
sacrifier h3 et au cavalier qui pourrait
venir faire échec sur trois ça a l'air
incroyablement lent parce qu'il a un
plan qui utilise trois coups de
cavaliers ont souvent dans les attaques
on essaye d'aller le plus vite possible
mais il la position est assez fermé le
centre est bloqué on voit qui aura pas
de contre jeu a priori de blanc sur au
centre ni à l'el dan donc fischer un peu
de temps il a quand même le temps de
faire ça tout à fait donc ici tour des
trois très bien donc ici tour des 3 de
la part de cochon alors l'intérêt de
tour des trois c'est que ça ici ça
libère l'action du funana et puis ça
évite plus tard car le cavalier il a vu
le corps je n'en ai signé sur cette
manière c'est comme une pas n'importe
qui là il a vu que sa tosca attaquer
donc i5 ou prophylactiques il évite la
taille de cette tour tout en garde un
atout regarder sur la troisième rangée
il sait très bien que tout ça est prêt à
sauter sur des sacrifices et donc il
faut essayer de contrôler au maximum un
autre intérêt aussi peut être de jouer
fou g4 est d'essayer de les changer des
pièces d' attaques contre ce fou ici qui
ne joue pas et ça permettra peut-être de
pourra pas de ramener un cavalier en
défense on peut aussi après envisagés
devront jouer cavalier d2 et cavaliers
facile des choses comme ça je vais tour
tour h3 pourront nationale pions ranger
4 sur une reprise
oui après six sélections revient h3 on
peut aussi envisager de la tour je
trouve 3 pourrait changer une pièce
d'attac et cette tournée aimerait bien
aussi sans doute venir ici ou là pour
essayer de défendre latéralement tout ça
alors qu'à believe cette non fish a
continué son plan est maintenant
regarder quand ce nom alors essayer de
verrouiller il joue sous f3 alors fouet
3 quel est l'intérêt de tous est roi
c'est patent de défendre
le cadre que de défendre eux deux mais
aussi pourquoi pas de jouer tour b 2
afin de défendre encore une fois les
défenses latérales sont très utiles
quand on a les blancs dans ces types de
deux parties est indienne il faut savoir
défendre latéralement et c'est bien
d'avoir des tours qui a foi son actif en
attaque et active en défense kabyle et
g5 sa part prône depuis trois ans et que
malheureusement ça enlève de la défense
a h3n2 alors dans me2 a pour intérêt de
défendre le 4 de garder eux deux mais
moi j'aurai peut-être préféré tours
tours b 2 puisque le client 4 as ont été
défendues pour l'instant par le cavalier
le fou est tombé de me semblait plus
quand même plus actif que ce coup de mou
et là regardez simplement toucher 6 elle
parle de fisher maintenant il se remet
on vit ça ici avec leur la menace à
l'éclair c'est qu'elle valait princes 3
gagnant gagnant qui alors ouvre la
colonne âge parce qu'après on pourra
revenir a réussi c'est pénétrer dans le
camp ennemi un hongrois et fin gourmet
évite encore une fois mais comme il sait
que maintenant de ce côté là il est plus
enfermer qu'autre chose il jouera elle
peut avoir une idée qu on essaie de
faire
fouad deux airois 2 1 puis roi des deux
puits s'échappent et du côté dames mais
il sera quand même beaucoup plus à
l'abri que là où évidemment ils échouent
alors c'est le moment pour fisher parce
que sinon le voir s'échapper un
magnifique
ces moments quadrillage 3 ça y est c'est
l'heure rial et on en a parlé d'eux
pendant longtemps la tour a été bloqué
par ce fou donc ce type de défense
finalement ne marche pas puisque après
j'ai prince francine on a perdu un pion
pour rien et puis la terre continue il
surtout surtout que l'attak continue
elle n'est pas finie et c'est g prend h3
et regarder la suite est magnifique fou
prend échec ça c'est pas bon signe le
fou quitter la 4c 8 on peut parier en
défense puisqu'ils à la tour
donc faut prendre soin obligé de donner
la dame on peut pas venir sur ces cases
là puisqu'il ya tour donc il ya un seul
coup pour les blancs vous pouvez trouvez
vous même ce héros f-22 ici qui est
forcé et là c'est quasiment matin donc
je n'aime pas si on peut pas imaginer
qu'elle allait prendre si on peut aussi
faire cavaler prendre des cinq peut-être
les choses comme ça on garde et pourquoi
elle plus que la dame qui rêvent de
venir en h4 et seimat
s'il n'y avait pas le cavalier dommage
cat nat donc quand on comprend ça il
suffit de comprendre qu'on veut s'il
suffit de libérer finalement ce cavalier
on pourrait aller dans des scènes
pourrait suffire mais fisher trouve
encore plus fort il fait qu'aller g4
avec échec donc là ça laisse même pas le
choix pour les noirs il ya qu un seul
coût acceptable c'est faire fi prend
alors nous on pourrait revenir ici en gm
puisque la tour maintenant est bloqué
ici alors dans ce cas là ça serait puni
trois échecs ou même cavalier deux cas
l'élève de échec parce qu'on peut pas
prendre à cause du mat
oui et sa bouche le fond donc ça permet
la dame devenir donc là ça oblige à un
coup comme roy h2 qui est forcé et on
peut prendre simplement la qualité
voilà c'est gagner c'est fini qu'on en
fait c'est même pas la peine de jouer
aussi la manche 4 on peut aussi
envisager d'un match 4 points que c'est
compliqué moi il ya comprendre là c'est
encore des coups il ya encore des coups
si on fait si on fait des matches 4 ici
et on pourra y découvrir en fonds
propres non simplement qu'ils allaient
prendre des 3 et que font les noirs
c'est chaud quoi si on prend ici en d2
simplement regarder des coucous midam g5
et on menace déjà matt tranquille on
peut aussi menacé fou g2 avec des échecs
sur la colonne h et le roi n'a pas de
case en fait il est complètement coincés
car les g4 échec
on n'a pas le choix si on n'y a là on
vient de voir confirmant la qualité plus
la tap qui continue il faut prendre et
l'a simplement regarder fischer se
presse pas il joue pas le fossat serait
faux de jouer d'un match 4 puisqu'après
eurois bouger mais la dame est attaqué
et si on prend le fouet mais la dame on
peut bien sûr mais il ya échange de
dames
hélas la taxe arrête donc il fait plus
fort
fou prend g4 et ses morts ses morts
parce que si on joue un coup comme dans
mes fins simplement regarder maintenant
on adam échec et on peut pas fuir tout
est pris donc on est obligé sur ce qu il
n'y a pas trouvé le coup légal
il y avait un panneau de ces deux
joueurs moi même j'ai deux par exemple
lâché 2 est là simplement je vous ai eu
deux échecs de la tour et voilà mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait on est obligé de
jouer food g3 est simplement on peut
prendre la dame puisque le fou ici est
cloué les noirs ramasse tout on ramasse
tout très simplement alors quoi d'autre
à part moi j'ai deux sur damas quatre on
peut envisager alors on peut envisager
mon peu après fou j'ai que plus proche
des 4 on peut imaginer que la dame
bailleur ou jouer tour f3 ou tooway
on pourrait imaginer essayons de voir
notre compte défense comme tour f3 pour
dire on donne la qualité et maintenant
il ya échec alors des échecs ou valleroy
encore une fois imaginons qu'il aille
mais on ne va pas aller en géant parce
que si on mangeait un c'est fou prend
tour échec avec le tour et on ramasse la
dame sans compter les maths donc ici par
exemple 3l fin et regarder tout
simplement continue avec damache un
échec
roy f2 encore d'un échec
uttam échec roi h1 et puis là c'est matt
après fou et trois échecs
il n'y a pas le choix il faut prendre
avec la tournée tour g1 et tomates
magnifique donc enfin d'abord il faut
manger 4c il n'y a pas de défense
tout simplement magnifique simple très
simple et voyez que le flou ne sort que
pour faire mal c'est à dire que c'est le
seul coup du fou il reste la partie sur
ses 8 et aura des mêmes cette tour elle
joue pas en fait elle joue juste un rôle
défensif et blanc n'ont pas réussi à
percer
or c'est typique ce parti est magnifique
parce que elle est jouée en blitz contre
corse 970 mais malgré tout on voit toute
la profondeur de jeu de fisher qui
connaît effet des finances sur le bouder
il connaît par coeur cette attaque il en
a joué des tonnes il connaît il sait le
jouer y compris au blitz de façon
parfaite il n'y auriez puissante
peut-être pas jouer autre chose en
partie lente en fait c'est possible sur
ces sur cette partie là à noter que par
rapport à ceux parker il disait dans son
livre je me sens meilleur parti sur une
partie espagnole
disons très l'arrachent parce que ça
veut dire qu'on joue mécaniquement en
fait pendant 20 30 coût parce que les
coûts sont quasiment naturelle à cette
époque qui connaissait et commencez à
connaître déjà les grandes lignes
ça veut dire qu'ils connaissaient tous
les coups par coeur mais toutes les
idées étant parfaitement connus les
coûts étaient naturels et le moment de
réfléchir venait bien plus tard dans la
partie
voilà donc on finit la ce cette émission
spéciale sur loup du fiff hier sur cette
magnifique victoire face à kornoi et se
résumer qui n'est pas exhaustive parce
que c'est impossible de faire d'eux
résumé david évidemment d'un homme de en
si peu de temps et notamment de bobby
fischer avec tout ce qu'il a pu lui
arriver
existence et qui dans la légende
maintenant absolument c'est là la grande
légende des échecs et puis un peu la
légende noire des échecs aussi comme
orfi il ya un côté aussi comme morphil
est venu il a été fulgurant ça a été
mais tu es une comète
et puis ensuite il a disparu ouais ouais
2-2 partie devient très très différentes
couper en 2 70 merci jérôme merci
c'était fait pour cette plongée dans
l'histoire de bobby fischer et je vous
dis moi au revoir à bientôt pour une
autre émission des gones à la tv sur les
grands champions du jeu d'échecs au
revoir au revoir